hi my name is natalie chang i would like
to propose a project that looks for
blood-based biomarkers for alzheimer's
disease
to give a bit of background about myself
i'm a junior at new rochelle high school
and my broad research interest is
alzheimer's disease
over the course of sophomore year i read
journal articles in order to learn more
about it and over the past several
months i've really focused on
blood-based biomarkers that can be used
to aid in alzheimer's disease diagnosis
now let me tell you a bit about why i
would like to conduct this research
alzheimer's disease which is a
neurodegenerative condition begins
affecting the brain approximately 15 to
20 years prior to the onset of symptoms
this asymptomatic phase is called the
preclinical stage and due to the length
of the preclinical stage it is difficult
to diagnose alzheimer's disease in its
early stages
additionally diagnosis relies on
clinical observation and additional
tests and there's no definitive way to
diagnose alzheimer's except for in
post-mortem examinations
some of the diagnostic tests that can be
used are cerebrospinal fluid testing and
brain imaging
for cerebral spinal fluid amyloid beta
levels and total tau as well as
phosphate levels can be taken into
account when diagnosing alzheimer's
disease as for brain imaging pet scans
can be used to look for amyloid plaques
and town neurofibrillary tangles while
mri can be used to look for brain
atrophy as indicators of alzheimer's
disease
to bring all of what i just said
together the current progression of
alzheimer's disease involves a
preclinical stage of 15 to 20 years in
which there are no symptoms
by the time symptoms do emerge
significant neurodegeneration has
already occurred
after an individual notices symptoms
they can be evaluated by a doctor who
may use cognitive tests cerebral spinal
fluid testing and brain imaging to aid
in diagnosis
once someone is diagnosed with
alzheimer's disease they can begin
receiving treatment but they may not be
a good candidate for clinical trials in
which potential interventions may be
most effective early on in alzheimer's
disease progression
an alternative to the current
alzheimer's progression would be to
screen people early on therefore
allowing us to diagnose and begin
treating people before the onset of
symptoms and before significant
neurodegeneration has occurred
if we're to screen people before
symptoms emerge we would have to rely on
biomarkers
current biomarkers however are
unsuitable for screening since cerebral
spinal fluid collection is invasive
brain imaging is expensive and both
types of testing are unsuitable for
general practice an alternative to these
tests would be blood tests which look
for blood-based biomarkers
it's important to note that even when
symptoms do appear it can still be
difficult to diagnose alzheimer's
disease
this is because mild cognitive
impairment one of the early stages of
alzheimer's is not exclusive to
alzheimer's disease
people with mild cognitive impairment
which is characterized by forgetting to
attend events poor judgment and
misplacing things frequently may remain
stable for an extended period of time or
progress to a non-alzheimer's disease
dementia therefore blood-based
biomarkers could be used to screen
people before the onset of symptoms or
to definitively diagnose people with
alzheimer's when symptoms do emerge
i mentioned that blood tests and
blood-based biomarkers could be an
alternative to other tests and
biomarkers but why exactly would
blood-based biomarkers be beneficial
well blood which circulates throughout
the body and interacts with the brain
via the blood-brain barrier contains a
variety of substances that can be used
as biomarkers such as proteins and rnas
found in blood cells and exosomes
additionally blood tests which are
minimally invasive easy to administer
and suitable for general practice may be
more cost effective than other tests
given how next generation sequencing has
become increasingly more affordable
with that said there are some challenges
involving blood-based biomarkers
for instance the blood-brain barrier
hinders the travel of substances between
the central nervous system and blood
which may make it difficult to use the
blood to measure happenings in the brain
additionally biomarkers for alzheimer's
disease may be expressed by non-cerebral
tissues therefore it may be difficult to
diagnose i mean it may be difficult to
determine which results are due to
alzheimer's disease and which can be
attributed to other factors
other potential issues are that
heterophilic antibodies may interfere
with immunochemical tests and protein
biomarkers may be broken down by
proteases in the plasma
a way to work around this last issue
would be to look for non-protein
biomarkers such as rnas
in summation the problem is that there
is no way to definitively diagnose
alzheimer's disease early on in its
progression be it in the pre-clinical
phase when there are no symptoms or the
mild cognitive impairment phase which is
not exclusive to alzheimer's disease
my goals are to identify blood-based
biomarkers that can be used to screen
for alzheimer's in the pre-clinical
phase and to indicate that someone with
mild cognitive impairment will develop
alzheimer's disease
in order to address these goals i looked
for data sets from the gene expression
omnibus that had expression data taken
from the blood
more specifically i looked for data sets
with samples from people who were
cognitively normal had mild cognitive
impairment and had alzheimer's disease
the first data set that i looked at
contains high throughput data on the
expression profiles of extracellular
rnas from plasma samples obtained from
the same participants every few years
one of the 35 people who of the 35
people who provided blood samples all
were 70 or older nine were controls that
were significant that were cognitively
normal throughout the sample collection
period 11 converted from cognitively
normal to mild cognitive impairment
during the collection period and 15 had
alzheimer's disease throughout the
collection period
this data set allows for comparison to
be made between people who converted
from cognitively normal to mild
cognitive impairment and age-matched
controls who remain
cognitively normal
while this dataset contains a lot of
valuable information it does not allow
for the determination of biomarkers that
may indicate that someone with mild
cognitive impairment is going to
progress to alzheimer's disease as
opposed to a different dementia to
address this gap i looked for another
data set
the second data set that i looked at
contains array data on the micro rna
expression profiles from serum
this data set has expression profiles
from people who had stable mild
cognitive impairment and people who
converted from mild cognitive impairment
to alzheimer's disease thus addressing
what the first data set lacked
having found two data sets i had a basic
idea that i wanted to do a comparison
within each data set and then look for
overlap between the results of these two
comparisons in order to make sure that
there would be any possibility of
overlap i first checked if the two
datasets had any overlap between all of
the micrornas measured
the two datasets had different names for
the micrornas with one using ensemble
ids and the other using version 21
mir-base accessions
in order to see if there was any overlap
between which micrornas were measured i
first needed to convert the datasets to
the same naming system so i started off
by using biomart to convert the ensemble
ids in dataset gse136243
to mir base ids
next i used the r package mir-based
converter to check what mir-based
version biomark converted the ids to and
i found that it was can that it
converted them to version 21 or version
22.
following this i used mir-based
converter to find the corresponding
mature micro rnas for each of the
mir-base ids and i then used mir-based
converter to convert the mir-based ids
to accessions
with the two data sets now using the
same naming system i compared them and
found enough overlap to proceed
my proposed methodology involves using
two data sets gse 136 243 and
gsu-150693 from the gene expression
omnibus
i plan to first work with gse 136 243
and my first step with this data set
would be to filter out all of the data
on expression of non-micrornas
next i will select samples from the
participants who converted from
cognitively normal to mild cognitive
impairment provided before they
converted
i will then look for differentially
expressed micrornas between these
samples and the samples provided by the
controls who remained cognitively normal
throughout the collection period
next i will use gse150693
to look for differentially expressed
micrornas between the participants who
converted from mild cognitive impairment
to alzheimer's disease and the
participants who had stable mild
cognitive impairment and did not convert
to alzheimer's
following this i will normalize the data
obtained from the two analyses since the
data from the two datasets was produced
with different acids
after this i will look for overlap
between the differentially expressed
micrornas found in the two
aforementioned comparisons and if i find
any i will annotate them through
literature review to see what genes they
may regulate and how those genes may be
related to alzheimer's disease
if i do not find any overlap i will
annotate the micrornas identified in
each separate comparison
tying this back to the bigger picture
this research could contribute to
finding blood-based biomarkers that
could potentially be used for screening
people for alzheimer's disease prior to
the onset of symptoms or for
definitively diagnosing individuals with
mild cognitive impairment who are going
to progress to alzheimer's disease
in addition to having a diagnostic role
identified micro rnas may also be
potential therapeutic targets because
research suggests that micrornas
regulate various genes involved with the
pathogenic pathways of alzheimer's
disease
i am very excited to have the
opportunity to conduct this research and
i hope that under the guidance of a
mentor i will be able to produce valid
results i have read several journal
articles in my field of interest and
taken the coding courses and
transcriptomics courses provided on the
onyx logic site
and i look forward to applying what i
have learned in this project
with that said i would love to be able
to consult a mentor if i have questions
regarding sections of code and
interpretation of statistical tests
to reiterate my name is natalie chang
and i would like to look for blood-based
micro-rna biomarkers for alzheimer's
disease diagnosis thank you so much for
your time